le cliquetis des armes est généralement
inquiétants menaçant mais dans cet art
mûri d'arlington en virginie
il est plutôt synonyme de bonne affaire
de 600 litres depuis plus d'un mois
ça ne dérougit pas jaune
le propriétaire vend des armes fusils
d'assaut ou des pistolets comme jamais
auparavant
trois ou quatre fois plus que d'habitude
et il croit que le corps à la virus y
est pour beaucoup
dès l'ouverture chaque jour les clients
faisaient la queue devant la boutique
ce qui l'a obligé à mettre en place un
système de rendez vous mais la boutique
de change est loin d'être une exception
les américains ont acheté deux millions
d'âmes
durant le mois de mars seulement un
record pour chanter c'est clair les gens
ont peur et la peur fait vendre
oui
deux heures de route à l'ouest une
vallée paisible de virginie occidentale
rien ici n'évoque l'anxiété est pourtant
sous ces cabanes de bois rond se
trouvent des bunkers des abris anti
atomiques
laurenti fortitude est en fait un
ensemble résidentiel fortifiées des
habitations ou emménagé en cas de
catastrophe
tout ou presque est déjà vendu résultats
de la pandémie au chan fort on a dix
fois plus de demandes que d'habitude dit
son gestionnaire vie les acheteurs qui
craignent le virus mais aussi et surtout
ses conséquences
ça peut engendrer des désordres civils
de l'instabilité des ruptures
d'approvisionnement explique-t-il on ne
parle donc plus de tenter de survivre à
la fin du monde mais bien plutôt de se
protéger en cas de couture beaucoup plus
probable au ranch
tout est prévu pour vivre en autarcie
complète les panneaux solaires coup la
génératrice pour l'électricité et des
stocks de nourriture pour un an
nous avons des produits séchés des
conserves du sucre de l'huile
précise-t-il et tout le nécessaire pour
la toilette le ranch dispose aussi d'un
arsenal impressionnant
les résidents ont donc les moyens de se
défendre
d arme de fort calibre un stand de tir
pour s'entraîner et le périmètre est
protégé par une série de tours de garde
il s'agit de toute évidence d'un secteur
d'activité très florissant les
propriétaires prévoient ouvrir quatre
installations similaires aux états unis
dès cette année ils ont aussi des
projets d'expansion au canada ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada lost city
en virginie occidentale